un défi qui s'annonce irréalisable le
ton est donné par les chefs
d'établissement à des lycées alors que
s'ouvre ce lundi la grande campagne
d'auto test auprès des lycéens
le projet du gouvernement en matière de
lutte contre le coc vide semble piétiner
avant même son lancement matériel en
nombre insuffisant manque de locaux
moyens humains trop peu nombreux et
pourtant c'est hot hot est présenté sous
forme de tests antigénique sur
prélèvement nasal était censé arriver
lundi dernier dans les lycées problème
tous les personnels n'ont pas reçu leurs
tests selon le ministère de l'éducation
nationale 60 millions d'autos tests
devraient être livrés d'ici l'été aux
établissements scolaires les premiers
entre le jeudi 6 mai et le 11 mai des
annonces loin de rassurer les principaux
syndicat des chefs d'établissement qui
pointe du doigt une mauvaise gestion de
ces tests certains même pas de gâchis en
perspective au vu du calendrier
face au manque de personnel pour faire
passer ces autos tests et les livraisons
au fil de l'eau la mise en place de ce
dépistage est impossible au lycée nous
conseillons très fortement à nos
collègues de ne prendre aucun risque
avec ces opérations on ne les réalisant
que si tout est uniquement toutes les
conditions sont remplies au regard des
préconisations sanitaires si les
livraisons d'autotest sont acheminés
trop tard dans les lycées une partie va
rester sur les bras de l'administration
car dès début juin les élèves ne seront
plus très nombreux à venir dans les
établissements livraisons retardées
autorisation des familles manquantes ou
encore mauvaise gestion du calendrier la
stratégie de dépistage du gouvernement
semble connaître un coup d'envoi raté
alors que le dispositif devrait être
élargi aux collégiens d'ici début juin